well we're officially in Austin
Texas
[Music]
and this is the first stream that we're
doing and the subject is
impossible
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh and it's already
this
but man it sure does appear like there's
a lot of
knowing oh
knowing where one
is knowing what one
is knowing lots and lots of beliefs and
assumptions and
ideas and defending
them oh oh boy this is a funny
one knowing lots of
objects endless
objects
it's
just
everything
already
apparently obsessing about being a
center inside of a
body and and
endlessly
boxing
everything
jeez oh the center
point which is an
illusion is so obsessed with
itself
[Music]
I've had a great day cold plunges
saunas setting this up
here the
studio yeah Center Point loves talking
about
itself it loves it
story well without its story it's not a
Center
Point without its story it's not a
location
without it's story it's not an
entity it's not a separate
individual and
so
the story is literally made of
Unknowing it's made of position
just
flowing what is
already
positionist
assumes the
position and a huge cloud of
knowing lots of ideas which
are which not only is that in itself
dualistic being a
position among
others so not only is that dualistic but
then the knowing
cloud is
dualistic because the knowing cloud is
all
about what is right and what is wrong
what is good and what is
bad and then it's
about
proving myself
worthy among
others by
showing how much
I know what is good and what is
right and earning lots of validation for
knowing it's fascinating one of the
comments is
about dropping ass
taking a
psychedelic what's funny is
that
this simply
this this
unknowing this position
position no
oness that is the natural state
so
no this is not a
psychedelic but to the separate
individual it is going to appear
psychedelic
because being no
thing
being
everything appears very psychedelic to
the separate
individual but really it is the sense of
me the sense of a center the sense of a
location and a position and a knowing
cloud and
Duality that is the most
psychedelic trip
imaginable
so that's actually the unnatural
State everything is obviously this
whatever is appearing obviously that is
blatantly
obvious within that natural no thing
being
everything
appears a sense of me a sense of a
center a sense of a
position a knowing Cloud
Duality and that is the psychedelic
trip somehow
nothing is appearing as
me
in one way that the knowing Cloud
can
see that it's actually
nothing it's actually wholeness there's
only
wholeness which is
unknowing which is in
infinite there are alpacas that are just
walking right by the window right now so
beautiful one way that that knowing
Cloud
can clearly see that it's actually
nothing is by
recognizing
that all of what has been
discussed so
far about a a
me uh story uh center location a
position an
obsessive compulsion
with taking ideas like a registar and
just
putting them into little boxes and
carrying around these boxes
everywhere is
hugely
conditioned
by parents by teachers by
Society
hugely because
child is taught that you're
unworthy until you prove yourself
worthy by being a very good
Center go be an
amazing sense of
me
so avoid anything that has to do with
nothingness avoid anything that has to
do with wholeness
avoid anything that has to do with
unknowing position
I lack I
[Music]
need
and this Center Point is going to be
obsessively trying to
get what it lacks and needs so it lacks
and wants validation it wants worthiness
it wants to prove Itself by knowing lots
of Concepts
and
dualisms it wants
to it already is no
one just pretending to be
me it's always no
one it's never actually
me
checking out the live
chat yeah so a knowing is the default
State it's the natural state it's the
Indescribable it's
wholeness it's what's always here
it's what everything's made
of the appearance is only
that and then within that arises
me which is
Duality me is
Duality because that means there are
others
that means I'm
real but it's still made of no one it's
still made of no
thing it's really exciting this first
stream in Austin because there's going
to be a lot more content that's like
this
so a lot more longer
form direct
streams likely even daily and sometimes
multiple times a day which is super
fun be pulling up stuff
online
there's also
bringing up topics on
screen and of course
there's there's guests that are sitting
across that will be sitting across this
table so there's already guests that are
being booked so there'll be continue to
be interviews also which is
fun there's already been uh some fun
comedians that have been reached out to
I'm so excited to banter with comedians
on the
Ridiculousness
of
this it's just
unfiltered hilarity
appearing it
is comedy
and that unconditional love that is this
that is
everything appears as War it appears as
separation it appears as military
industrial complexes it appears as
pharmaceutical industrial
complexes it appears as Center points
that have billions of dollars that do
not want to
share nothing is appearing as all of
that unconditional love unconditional
Freedom
wholeness is appearing like all of those
things
that's why it's so
[Music]
funny oh there's a comment from Comedy
Mothership that's right let's
go it's likely just an account called
comedy WEA ship but
comedy mothership is such a crucial
Cornerstone to Austin and to Comedy and
to free
speech and to
playfulness
and
actually in doing so it's a Cornerstone
for
wholeness
really good comedy which is something
that this is now becoming more and more
excited
about at least here seems to do seems to
be a lot
with breaking
boxes
those
contractions in the
body a hi
teacup or year and a half old a dog here
is cutely looking through the
window that is so commonly like seen
like that contraction in the body comes
to a comedy set and
then it can relax it
can
detent it can
unwind it can
laugh
so comedy is such an exciting part of
the show and the
Dow home Dow decentralizing basic needs
infrastructures being here in Austin
yeah that's
great it's great seeing in the
chat
they being
wholeness discuss and wholeness both
being discussed with the w wholeness and
also wholeness being discussed with the
H and you can also write wholeness with
the w but make it lowercased and then
with a capital
H and which kind of gets them both into
one visual
word
because there is
that and only
that and then it appears within that A
Center Point a
me can
arise and can feel like lack can
feel
seeking seeking is
hilarious
seeking is so
funny oh
boy when the
Seeker dissolves
it's
seen by no one that it never
was it never
was
oh it is so
funny
H earlier
today I met someone
and there was a conversation that they
started about their Awakening
experience and
and
this
before would have been so wow Awakening
experience tell me
more I'll listen to your Awakening
experience and then you listen to my
story of a
me that's
Awakening
and and today it was just clearly seen
that by nothing that it's just Beauty
appearing that
way and that
graspin isn't
there
isn't it fascinating how when that
elusory Center Point forms and then
becomes a
seeker and then goes on a transformative
Journey that it becomes narcissistically
obsessed with its story
[Music]
it's story becomes so
inflated it becomes so
complex all the me wants to do is talk
about how complex it's story through
time and space and contraction and
expansion is how many meditation
Retreats it's been on which grus it goes
and sits with which psychedelics it's
taken
braah which ones have you done
brah when was the last time you did one
bra
because that's going to tell me that
you're super
awake which books have you
read or the religious ones
too bro do you even know the three
characteristics
bro do you know the Ten
Commandments and then it's
always funny looking at
the cat or the
dog that
just comes over and just
purs or the dog that just looks up and
just wants you to pet can we cuddle
please or are you too busy in your cloud
of
knowing
so no
one is liberated
and the illusion of me is about
avoiding
nothingness it's about
seeking experiences
to try to get itself out of the
experience of Separation which isn't
actually
happening
[__]
it's cool I'm reading the chat go go do
whatever you
need because there'll be a lot more of
these playful streams soon and jam ass
community on them be
fun
it's
fun how interesting I see there's was
wholeness written with the capital H
lowercase w Capital H and then zero and
one Hess that looks so
cool
nice
wow
h
yeah this
natural
[Music]
unknowing
wholeness it's
ineffable all these
words can't box
everything you're just pointing to the
apparent illusion that's happening
within
everything
and then that apparent
Center just can't quite find what it's
missing because it's
obviously not a center and there's
nothing that's
missing and so no matter where that
elusory Center goes and seeks whatever
it's looking
for experiences or material
possessions or substances or
relationships
travel
luxuries reading books being very
morally in a straight
jacket and it never finds it never finds
and it's so upset cuz it's always just
bouncing from experience to experience
to experience looking and looking and
looking and talking about its
experiences hey let me tell you about
what happened in my travels in this
place that I was in these substances I
took how it helped me in this
way and it's always centerless it's
always position it's always unknowing
it's always the
whole that is hilariously talking about
an ucer me that is on an ucer
journey to try to find what's not
missing seeking boils down to finding
what's not
missing
looking for what's not
missing looking for what can never be
missing what can never be missing in
Infinity is the absolute which is
this oh
yes I see in the
chat there's
a there's an inquiry about checking out
the
space which
I mean it's it's uh I mean you can see
it from this angle
too there's a guest shot that's lined up
here so that's where the guest the guest
sits across the table right
there there's
another sure mic there and this this is
the camera that that one is the one
that's on and there's one on
the the guest there's also a table
shot you can see there's a table shot
there there's also
a there's also
a
another
wireless mic
that I'll be wearing and using it's just
not as obviously
crisp and clear as these sm7 DBS and
this is uh was another
request this
is a wood block
drum do
do only Hess only holess I've been
uh I actually I first discovered this in
uh in bodaya which is where Buddha was
enlightened there were a bunch of monks
from I believe Thailand that
were going at it drumming and
chanting almost all day and was
beautiful sitting with them for
hours
yeah and you see you can
uh there's so many of these by the way
that I've
been
recording as teasers in a
way
I can give you uh
what's what's felt like is one of my
favorites it's
uh what was that it's like
the I guess it's the anthem it's like
the anthem of Unknowing or the anthem of
the
ineffable zero
boxes zero
boxes
not name not form not time not space not
gender or ethnicity not nation state or
politics not science or
religion not self not Soul not right not
wrong not even
Consciousness zero
boxes zero
boxes so yeah that's the the
anthem of Unknowing of the
ineffable zero
boxes zero boxes not name not form not
time not space not gender or ethnicity
not nation state or
politics not science or religion not
self not Soul not right not wrong not
even Consciousness zero boxes zero
boxes sing
along let's do another
round zero
boxes zero boxes not name not form not
time not space not gender or ethnicity
not nation state or
politics not science or religion not
self not Soul not right not wrong not
even
Consciousness zero
buckes zero
boxes love it this so cool got zero
boxes nice tone thanks guys so
cool I appreciate you
too yes Pure Freedom that doesn't know
it's Pure Freedom hm mhm no one left to
know no one left to
grab no one left to
box it just
is what
always
is
it's cool that we got zero boxes out
into the ether
on this for stream in
Austin that's great thanks for
asking
you know and there's the comment like if
you had top book
recommendations I
just before leaving to Austin I just
gave away donated
all the books that I own all of
them I don't own any more
books
so in a way it's like a
testament when no one is there and
nothing can no longer be
gotten it's just
wholeness there's no there's no lack
like that that tension in the body which
is like I must read need I must learn I
must acquire
Concepts to be
worthy you know it's just that's not
there it's not
there and the other thing is that
me
will always want what's not
this me will always want what's not
this so me is always looking for hey man
where did you go on that 10day
Meditation
Retreat hey man who was your shaman on
that 5 Meo DMT
Journey hey man give me the those book
recommendations and the other part of
that comments about you know like
appreciating
mind this doesn't even know what a mind
is don't even know what Consciousness
is
there's apparently a
body and the body
apparently has
brain
with eyeballs that
are the nervous system jutted
out
but it's
hilarious
watching science
and Consciousness
researchers in ask being
nothing trying to box nothing it can't
can't happen it can't be
boxed there's no way that it can be
boxed that's what
unknowing
the
boxes it's impossible to know your way
to something that isn't
lost it's impossible to experience your
weight out of a me that isn't
there yeah me w wants meaning me wants
purpose and those put everything into
boxes
everything is something an object that's
happening to an elusory center point
it's happening to me and it means
something so important in my life my
journey through space and time where I'm
still looking
for
something that will make me whole when
I'm
already no
thing and
so no meaning and no
purpose are another way of saying
absolute unconditional
freedom and
me apparently freaks
out because
it oh my gosh what about the dualisms of
morality oh my
gosh if there's no meaning or no purpose
and if everything's just absolute
unconditional
Freedom
then there's a higher likelihood that
there will be malevolence and violence
and all these bad things that
happen actually me is what is
manipulating what's
appearing me with its
neuroticism is what
creates mutually assured
destruction
wholeness which is what that me illusion
is made of wholeness no
[Music]
thingness
unknowing position losness that is
unconditional love that is unconditional
Freedom
me can't
know it can't
get
what isn't
missing the love and freedom that me
looks for is always
conditional while it's made of
unconditional love and freedom
and the body has a natural and
spontaneous
way without an appropriation of a me or
a center that is doing or willing or
choosing which are again just conceptual
boxes the body naturally
spontaneously goes to take a
piss you see when the bladder is
full there's
just
apparently body going to bathroom to
pee there's no me or there's no Center
Point that
decides oh my bladder is full so now I
will will my body up and walk it to the
bathroom is just an appropriation of a
natural spontaneous response of the
body wholeness bodying
apparently
and there's so many examples like that
there's no
controlling
these autonomous
blinks or these
autonomous
breaths or these autonomous
heartbeats
or blood pressure or digestion you know
imagine like
eating eating and then like I'm eating
I'm
swallowing I'm digesting oh I'm
commanding my biology I'm
commanding all of the biological
processes to break down the food foods
and Supply the body with its nutrition
and I'm commanding when I
[Music]
poop it's just an
appropriation it's a hilarious
appropriation
so freedom is always
already always
already
so the body is already
Freedom it's already wholeness it's
already unknowing it's already the
ineffable
bodying it's already what's
position
bodying and
so when the body
moves that's what's already
free move moving
apparently so it's not like the body's
going to move and then go to a retreat
or read a book
or or get that material possession or
that relationship and then it will be
free then it will be whole then it will
attain Enlightenment because there is
only no
thingness there is only Enlightenment
there is only Pizza
everything is that everything is
that so if you want to call everything
pizza or
ocean whatever you want to call no
thingness whatever you want to try to
put as a word to everything or the
ineffable or all that
is
oh nice yeah this these OB spots are
great because they have a they have a
feature where if you go like
this they'll track you and so in this
case I just turn tracking
off and then you can turn tracking back
on and then you can also then do this
and you'll get a 2X or so Zoom which is
nice
so it's always already free it's always
already
wholeness it will never be found because
it's not
lost it will never be found because it's
not
lost the body itself is an effable
position
Perfection it's already centerless
Freedom love
wholeness it's already that it's always
already
that so you can say there's a story of a
child that is apparently born and then
conditioned and then forms a center
point and then goes on a expansive
transformative
journey and then
recognizes the emptiness that always
already
was but that's just a
story that's just the unbounded
unconditional Freedom appearing as that
story so that's why it's not worth
mentioning that's why it's not worth
worth
mentioning
so and asked hey like tell me about your
transformative journey in
Awakening it's not worth
mentioning because it never
happened there was never a me that went
through a transformative
Journey
and until that is
clear and as long as it's not there's
still a center point that is obsessive
Center
pointing OCD obsessive Center Point
disorder that's another whole thing that
will come forth on these streams as
bringing up fun things like that and
noticing how the
entire quote psychological
literature is all written from the place
of self and other it's all written from
Duality
so actually
dissociation from wholeness is
association with me
so we'll get into more of
that it is never
lost that's another fun
one I don't specifically have one that's
written for this but it is never lost it
is never lost it is never lost lost
impossible to lose impossible to lose
never
lost never
lost never lost or found never lost or
found never lost or found
impossible to lose impossible to lose
never lost never found never lost never
found never lost never found never lost
never found never lost never found let's
go I'm so excited for these spontaneous
freestyles and streams I'm so
excited that's why the wood block is
right
here never lost never
found yeah so fun things like that will
spontaneously come up
and and there's excitement here
about the
spontaneous uh beats and freestyles to
get repurposed freely of course it's a
dow it's a decentralized autonomous
organization
so feel free to repurpose it and then
throw it in jams and all kinds of things
and just creating more beats and
freestyles it's so
exciting and this is approximately the
length that is
feeling
good link that's
feeling like it allows the
flow this is just hitting an
hour and it really feels like there's a
there's a flow there's a stride there's
a everything just gets
to spontaneously arise and get
explored and that's why these longer
streams
feel good they feel
good so that's looking
like
what these will be
so yeah it's impossible to ever
lose it's impossible to
find because it's already
it's really simple it's super simple and
ordinary it's absolutely not
extraordinary so extraordinary is about
me and story and experiences and
extraordinary it's about
specialness it's about me being
special and
specialness just wants to talk about
itself it wants the illusion of others
to listen
to its specialness its experiences its
stories
and again it's funny because it's
wholeness that
is
apparently elusory
meing or
selfing
no one
knows this
Freedom right there no one
knows
unknowing position lless
centerless
wholeness
Freedom unconditional
love
Infinity that no one
knows it's not found in an
experience because it's
already it's
already and there's already not a me
there already not a center
point it's already not
there it's just an
illusion that's why all this web 3 Dow
decentralized autonomous
organization
stuff is like the evolution of the
internet especially with with home Dow
and
backing these new
tokens with real world NextGen
infrastructures like sustainable
regenerative
housing NextGen
energy Food Water Systems
comedy lots of fun communal spaces for
sports and hanging
out music play children being free
decentralized basic needs is about
children being free not having to enter
into the
Matrix and
sell apparent time for apparent money to
pay for apparent basic
needs
to just be free so Dows are really
exciting and Dows
are really is what is what is is
dawing and then me which is an illusion
forms
centralized
architectures
that that apparently create
more body tensions of
meis whereas
Dows
apparently
relieve the body
tensions into the wholeness that always
already is
always already no separation
anywhere always already no separation
anywhere
it's impossible to
say but even these words are just what
is
ising
freedom is always
already H it's so always and already
it's inconceivably always and
already oh
boy
just do everyone a favor
and laugh
at the apparent mes and spiritual
seeking just pointing to the always
already that's
there and it's that same Freedom that's
appearing
as an assumption of a me that that's on
a transformative Journey
so it's
really it's so funny
that me that is on a transformative
journey is actually made of Unknowing
it's made of
nothing it's made of
wholeness it's made of its absence the
meos spiritual transformative journey is
made of its absence
already
gosh that is so
funny oh
man
[Music]
h
freedom of
Unknowing and the unconditional
love for
whatever is
ising whatever is
appearing
[Music]
h
so all of it is a story all of
it the whole stream itself is a
story because nothing is ever
lost
oh
[Music]
boy and nobody gets to
own an
entainment me wants to own an attainment
called Enlightenment as a North star or
as a gold star that it gets to put on
its
forehead and then use that to be
worthy
oh and it's never
lost and it's never
attained so you can get up from whatever
gurus
and treats and books and just be looking
and just be like what it's never
lost there only
wholeness or if you're looking on the
smartphone or computer screen at the
[Music]
stream it's never
lost there's only
wholeness
there's only what's not separate and
what's without
position there's only that
unknowing
ineffable
so right there that's that's
it the phone or the computer or the guru
or Retreat or psychedelic or trying to
chase be seeking or whatever all those
things
[Music]
just
oh
this is no
one this is no one being
everything
yay
looks like a bit of
a
[Music]
function
what these
uh unconditional love of the cats and
the dogs that
are he's such a huge favorite of of
people you know just coming up and or
even the you know the innocence of the
the baby or the child is just you know
like that way that cats like to rub on
the it's just that unconditional love
and
the Innocence really when the UN
knowing
[Music]
well getting a bit tired and that's all
that can
be apparently said about this for
now and nothing can ever be said about
what already is the freedom that is
everything
everywhere all
at
once all right
as always that unconditional
love it's always and already
already so
pumped so
pumped was so much more so much more
play it's so exciting
much
comedy humor
chest basic needs
infrastructures
Freedom so
beautiful
always and
already